so it's that time of the year again
things are starting to warm up
it's past mother's day now and we want
to get out in our yard and we want to
plant a garden
but like a lot of us we don't like
watering those gardens so i have a great
solution and alternative for you that's
cheap and effective
so let's get started
[Music]
so this is my backyard area we have
three raised beds here
in my backyard we started this about
three years ago
they're just made of out of two by sixes
with a post
in the corner and then we basically
brought in a leaf compost
uh you could call it topsoil if you want
but it was a leaf basically i'd leave
compost and filled them in
and we started our garden like i said
about three years ago so like i said we
started this about three years ago
um we have a bunch of vegetables in here
we have tomatoes cucumbers we have
asparagus
we actually have some strawberries um so
we really enjoy that um that's something
that my family really likes to do some
organic
gardening um so basically what i'm gonna
show you today
is drip irrigation i know a lot of us
out there think of drip irrigation i
think
it's a lot of work but it's not it's
actually
a lot of fun you can customize it so i'm
going to show you how i did my
raised garden beds back here and how you
can do it at your home as well
so basically what drip irrigation is
it's basically tubing
that runs throughout your yard and you
have basically emitters
that run off of it into your various
plants
this is a half inch pipe here they sell
in a
uh 100 feet at home depot and i believe
they sell it at lowe's as well
um this hundred foot pipe is less than
10 bucks
um basically from here you would connect
it to a water timer
i'll show you that in a couple minutes
um and then basically off of here
you can run lines to your plants so like
i said home depot sells this rain bird
water timer i've had this for two
seasons now i haven't had any problems
with it
it just hooks up to my faucet here
basically what's really cool about this
is it's battery operated you can turn
the dial you can set the clock you can
set the duration to how
long you want you can have it come on
two times a day if you would like
you can have it come on any day the week
every day a week however long as you
want
you can also have a manual turn on here
as well
and there's also a rain delay as well
here
like i said two seasons i haven't had a
problem with this and it's only 35 bucks
at home depot
from there what you're gonna do is
you're gonna connect
your um water here basically you have
your half
inch line come down here you have a
couple connections here
that go into a backflow preventer here
and then your half inch line is just
going to go out underneath
your ground and into where you want it
out in your yard so like i said i have
my half inch line here
i just run it down in my mulch bed here
and i just have it buried and it
basically goes along my house here
and it goes all along here
and then i have a turn here they sell
elbows that you can cut and easily put
together
and it goes all underground here
we're going to go into my backyard
and then basically what happens is it
goes along here underground
all the way back to my raised beds so
once we come around my fence line here
we come up here and then we connect in
here again to another half inch and i
have this just long
run along the middle of the raised bed
here
and then basically what these uh brown
ones are
these are four inch emitters so they're
spaced out
four inches apart and basically they
emit water
out into your garden it's a really cool
feature
they're really easy to hook up to your
half inch line here with
the adapters that they bought you can
buy at the store
and i just have that run around my
garden
um and then also in the middle of my
garden in certain areas i have these
larger
adapters here that they just plug in and
they also
emit water as well so what i'm going to
do next
is i'm going to turn on this section
here so you guys can see what it looks
like
coming out of the water lines so like i
said it's really easy to manually turn
this on
you're gonna hit the water nail you're
gonna just set your duration
um i have it already set here for 10
minutes and you just hit
ok and then the water is going to start
flowing out
through your system and we're going to
go back and check it out at the raised
bed now
so we're back out to our raised bed here
um as you can see here
our emitters they are dripping here
every four inches
um and what's really cool about this
line is you can have it maneuver
wherever you want
you could have it run like a snake you
could have it run it directly over your
plants
where they're at um this section of my
garden right here is asparagus
as you can see here you have these
emitter as emitters as well
these ones emit out more water than
these ones
um so they're really great for shrubs uh
flowers plants whatever you can put
these wherever you want
so this section over here we just put
these in
this year these raised beds um we have
some various vegetables throughout here
um what's really cool about over here is
we also have the emitters
as well uh they're spaced out four
inches
um basically i'm just using these uh
staples
uh here to clamp them down and then from
here
they also sell these uh poly tube here
these are a solid tube and what's really
cool about these tubes are
is you can pretty much run these tubes
to out
anywhere you want so for example
this tube basically runs
and connects all four or actually all
three
of these raised beds together and then
this tube here
runs underground and then it comes
through this garden here
and then my half inch poly tube
is underground there and i have it just
connected to there
so that main water source is putting
that water
through that small tube here and it's
coming through here
and it's connecting these three raised
beds together
and they're all getting the drip
irrigation together so you're probably
wondering by now
how easy is it to do it joe it's really
easy
anybody can do it my wife's done it um
i've showed her how to do it she can do
it
uh anyone can do it so let's i'm gonna
show you a couple examples
of how to get connections off of your
main water line here
so let's just use this pipe here as an
example let's just say that your timer
is down here
and then your end point is down here so
what you're going to want to do
is when you have various points where
you want to
connect off of it they sell this punch
tool here
it's a really cool tool all you do is
basically
put a little bit of pressure and you're
going to just make a little hole here
and then from there they sell these
little barb
here this is a straight one it has a
connection on both ends
all you're going to do is basically push
that in there
and once you hear that popping noise
that you know that that's in there
and then from there you can connect your
four inch spacing
emitters if you want but for this
example what i'm going to show you is
how to make an extension off of this
so basically you have your smaller poly
tube here
and then you can just connect that to
here
it's really hard sometimes to connect
these together
so what i like to do is either get a
blowtorch here
i got this at harbor freight it's pretty
inexpensive you just put a butane at the
bottom
you can also even use a lighter as well
basically what you want to do is just
heat up this section here a little bit
it's a little windy today
just a little bit and then from there
you're just going to feed that onto your
barb there
and then it's connected and then at the
other end you can connect these little
emitters here um these come in a pack a
10 pack here
i believe they're i think they're less
than
two dollars or three dollars something
like that um you can find these at home
depot or lowe's
these put out two gallons per hour
i don't get caught up in that too much i
just look out at my plants if they need
a little bit more water
i adjust my timer that way i don't get
too caught up in the gallons per hour
but basically from here you're going to
take your poly tube here and you're
going to connect it together
and again these poly tubes are a little
bit hard to connect
so what i like to do is just heat up the
end a little bit here
once i can get it to go
[Applause]
and then you can just connect the green
end
to here and again you can easily
cut this tube um what i use to cut this
is basically uh this
knife here it's used for pecks um again
you can find these pretty much at any
hardware store as well
um so if you have to cut this it's very
easy to cut
you just clamp that on and it cuts right
off
and then from there they also sell these
adapters as well they sell straight ones
they sell the
elbows as i have here and all you got to
do is basically just feed this on
until it gets pretty tight and then you
have your connections there
another great thing they sell is these
little goof
plugs so basically what happens is if
you make a mistake
uh in your main water line here um or if
you want to stop
uh one of these lines as well which can
be cut with a pair of scissors
as well what basically what you do is
say if i had a hole
in my line here and i didn't want that
line anymore or that hole there anymore
you can just take one of these goof
plugs and you can
just snap those in there
and you're good to go so here's a
perfect example here
of how to use that extension that i just
showed you
in your various plants in your yard i
have here blueberry bushes we have them
along a our fence line here they come
from hamilton
new jersey a lot of you don't know but
hamilton's actually the blueberry
capital of the world
um there's more blueberry plants there
than i've ever seen
the blueberries are just the best so we
went down there a couple years ago and
we picked up some
and we put them out in our yard so
basically what i did was is
i have my half inch line underground
here that runs back
to my garden bed but what's really great
about the half inch line is you can just
branch off of that
to other various parts of your yard so
that's basically what i did here
um i have my tubing come out for my half
inch
with my straight barb connector like i
just showed you
um and then from there i've run my poly
tubing to the
drip uh emitter here and then what's
really cool
is they sell these stakes as well um and
you can just connect these
to the end here you can just place them
to the base of the plant and you can
just
easily segregate basically what each
plant
is and you can easily segregate water
into each plant
so i have them go into each of the
blueberry bushes and it's really easy
to keep them ordered as well and
basically i have that seeing concept
along
my flower beds as well each of these
plants along my flower bed here
has that same extension concept as the
blueberries do
so what's really great is you can keep
your rose bushes
you can keep any kind of shrub that you
have watered
and basically i just have that half inch
line just keep running along
my mulch line there along the edge of my
house and i can easily just branch
off of there and get each of these
plants
enough water to last out through the
summertime so that's pretty much it
today i just wanted to show you the drip
irrigation in my yard
um like i said i've had this for about
three years now i love it
it just runs so smoothly we can keep all
of our plants nicely water throughout
the spring and the summertime
our garden loves it it's really easy to
do
you can probably do it less than a
hundred bucks maybe even a
less than 50 bucks depending on the size
of your garden
or your yard i think it's really
inexpensive
so you don't really have to worry about
watering anymore you just set that timer
and go if you found this content helpful
today make sure you smash that like
button it helps out with the channel
helps out with the youtube algorithm so
other people can find my channel
if this is your first time watching the
video please consider subscribing
to my channel it's an all organic lawn
channel i have no herbicides in my lawn
that's what i strive for i have kids i
don't want any kind of chemical in my
lawn
so please if you're new please consider
subscribing to my channel
just a quick note for the products that
were used in today's video
pretty much everything can be found at
home depot or lowe's
they pretty much have the same variation
of the drip irrigation adapters
at either store the only thing i didn't
purchase at home depot or those was the
brown uh garden adapter um the four inch
spacing i couldn't get the four inch
spacing at home depot or lowe's
so i actually got that off of rain birds
website
so if you want a four inch spacing
please check out the rain bird site
i'll leave all the links to the products
in the video description
below if you have any questions or
comments please comment below
i will get back to you i tried to go as
quickly as possible on the content today
so please if you have any questions on
what i did or how to do it
please comment below and i'll see you
in the next one
[Music]
you